foreign
I keep rewriting the old stuff what ifs
and hypothetical does not really matter
in here and do they nothing matters in
this world and Tessa's not here
I hope you're making progress on the new
book everyone is dying to see it and I'm
afraid I can't keep putting people off
can't rush greatness can you
hang a dollar advance
play that Nazi over Christmas she asked
after you she moved to Lisbon Lisbon
[Music]
what are you doing okay making amends
you need to leave
I really wish I could just go back I've
moved on and so should you I know who
you are you are up to me you'll be
rotting yourself
so scared of failing so I just end up
ruining everything instead if I didn't
have her I wouldn't have the book but if
I didn't have the book then I would
still have her
I'm not ready to move on
can't just talk about us like that I
can't imagine living another moment on
this Earth without you by my side test
[Music]
without you
there is only me
broken
lost and alone
it's easy to believe our ability to love
is finite especially when your heart is
broken Believe It or Not slowly you will
heal
you never know how lucky you are to
spend the rest of your lives with the
other half of yourself
until you've had to spend your life
without them
you know I read your book
so what happened
to Tessa
[Music]
[Applause]